Yoshua Bengio: So I think I showed this already to Frederick. Oh, come on.
Computer, wake up.	All right, so we've worked for a few years on using deep learning information translation.
We've been able to reach the state of the art, and improve on the state of the art, using deep learning, and now,
other groups in the world are working on this, and it's pretty exciting.
But maybe not as exciting as seeing what happened
when we take the same technology that we use for our machine translation that goes, say, from French to English,
and apply it to translating from images to English.	And so it does things like this.
You show the picture like this,
and the computer generates an actual language sentence that's kind of a description like,
"A woman is throwing a Frisbee in a park."
Interviewer: The computer generates that?
Yoshua Bengio: Yes, and it would do a different sentence next time if we try, all right?
And it's kind of generating somehow with some kind of randomness.
There are many possible sentences you could say about this image,
and it really learns about all the kids of sequences of words that are appropriate..
Interviewer: What kind of other sentences could be [inaudible 00:01:59].
Yoshua Bengio: Well, so here is some more, like here..
Interviewer: I mean for this same image.
Yoshua Bengio: Oh, I could image ir could say, "Two people in a park with green lawn." Simple, short sentences.
The computer was trained by imitating humans that have typed these kinds of short sentences.	About 80,000 images
and 5 sentences for each image were labeled by humans, so that's supervised learning.
The human is telling the computer, "So for this image,
here is what I would say." And "Here's another sentences I could say." Different people produce different sentences for
the same image. That's how it was trained. It knows there is some diversity in what could be produced.
For each of these images,
what we see also is the particular system we developed uses what's called an "at attention mechanism." It's paying
attention to particular places in the image at different points in the sequence as it's generating each word.	It
generates one word after the other, in order,
and as it's going to be generating the word "Frisbee," it's looking around the image
and focusing on the place where there's the Frisbee. So that part is interesting because it's not so supervised.
We didn't tell the computer, "When you're going to say that word,
you should be looking here in the image." It figured out by itself that this was useful to look at the right places as
it's producing each of the words in the sentence.
Interviewer: So it has a lot of words in the system?
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah, I don't know, something like 100,000 words.
Interviewer: And then it finds a connection by itself with the image?.
Yoshua Bengio: Yes, by itself...but it's been trained..
Interviewer: Yeah it's been trained,.
Yoshua Bengio: ...on a lot of the..
Interviewer: but It can also generate different sentences for the same image.
Yoshua Bengio: I don't have that example, but I can tell you that it does.
It's also useful to see sort of what's going on inside the machine, this attention, right?
So here, where it says, "A dog is standing on a hardwood floor," it's looking at the dog, and so on.
Like here, it's saying, "A group of people sitting on a boat in the water," and it's looking at the people,
so the underlying word here is the word at which we are going to display the attention picture, where it's focusing.
This attention is also useful to debug, to understand the mistakes. So here is some mistakes that it makes.
For example, in this picture, it says, "A woman holding a clock in her hand." It's getting confused because you see
when it says "clock," which is obviously wrong, it's looking at the round pattern on her shirt.
It thinks that the letters here maybe are the numbers in the clock, so it's making this mistake.
These are, maybe it doesn't have enough resolution to make out those details.
That's quite possible here.	Also,
this system was trained on a fairly small data set compared to what's needed to really do that job well.
For example, our friends at Facebook, they trained a system on a lot more data.
Of course, this is sort of using their own internal data. Let's see if I still have this.
When the system was trained with more data, and also, to do something a bit hard, which is to answer questions,
so this comes from Facebook, my colleague's Facebook, [inaudible 00:05:57] one.
Computer Ask: Is there a baby?
Computer Answer: Yes.
Computer Ask: What is the man doing?
Computer Answer: Typing.
Computer Ask: Is the baby sitting on his lap?
Computer Answer: Yes.
Computer Ask: Are they smiling?
Computer Answer: Yes..
Yoshua Bengio: I'm not so sure that they are smiling, but I guess the man may be sort of smiling. This is..
Computer Ask: Is there a baby in the photo?
Yoshua Bengio: ...more impressive, this one.
Computer Answer: Yes.
Computer Ask: Where is the baby standing?
Computer Answer: Bathroom.
Computer Ask: What is the baby doing?
Computer Answer: Brushing teeth.
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah, that's not obvious.
Computer Ask: What game is being played?
Computer Answer: Soccer.
Computer Ask: Is someone kicking the ball?
Computer Answer: Yes.
Computer Ask: What color is the ball?
Computer Answer: Yellow.
Yoshua Bengio: Or green maybe?
Computer Ask: What game is the dog playing?
Computer Answer: Frisbee.
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah, so you see it's the same theme, right?
We have a new one at work that analyzes the image,
computer representation of it.	I can go back here so you can get a sense of what I mean.
Interviewer: Is this your own presentation?.
Yoshua Bengio: That presentation? Yeah, these are my slides, yeah. So basically, that's actually..
Interviewer: Oh, that's interesting.
Yoshua Bengio: ...It's showing how the image is going to be transformed in different stages,
and so what we mean by deep is basically just that there are many such stages.
So the classical way of doing neural networks, there was only two stages because we didn't know how to train them..
But we have found ways to train much deeper ones since then. That's basically started in 2006, this..
Interviewer: Global?.
Yoshua Bengio: Being able..
Interviewer: Canadian.
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah, yeah.
That's Canadian conspiracy, that's right.	Let me show you some more things that are fun.	So another interesting...oh,
actually, we're going to meet my brother, Sammy. Here's his picture.
And some of the work he's done in that field is to use these approaches to learn to transform both images
and text to the same space.
An image is transformed into a point in some space, and if you type something like,
"dolphin" is also transformed into the same space.
And if both the word and image go nearly near to each other,
and it's a good cue that they mean something related.	So if you are in Google image search,
and you're searching for images of dolphin, what's going to happen is,
it will computer this representation for the word, dolphin, and then look for images that have a representation nearby,
and then show you those images. So this notion of intermediate representation is very very important in deep learning.
That's really want makes the whole thing work. We're not trying to go directly from inputs to decisions.
We have these intermediate stages, intermediate computations, or intermediate representations, as we call them,
that can be more abstract, as we consider deeper systems.
Interviewer: Does it mean that you are on the right track? It completes the goal yet?
But you're on the right track, in the right direction?
Yoshua Bengio: Well, yeah, that's what we believe.
Future researchers will prove us wrong, as usual,
but currently the evidence is strongly suggesting that this idea of having multiple levels of representation is working
really well.
So we have both these kinds of experiments, as you've seen,
that show the system doing things thanks to these deep architectures.	Also,
we're starting to understand more theory why it's happening like that, although,
much more theory probably needs to be done.
But I think there are lots of good reasons to believe that this concept of having multiple levels of representation is
quite important.
And we have also the evidence from our brain that it's actually doing something similar.	So if you look at it kind of
like a map of what's happening in the visual cortex, which is the part of the brain that processes images,
and that's also the part that we understand the best, the information goes from your eye,
through different regions in your brain that have little names like LGN, B1, B2, B4, and so on,
and at each of those stages, they correspond to the layers in our simple models.
And the information becomes more represented in an abstract way.	So at the lower level,
the brain recognizes very local things like edges, and as you go higher up, it starts recognizing little pieces
and shapes and eventually, around here, it's actually recognizing actual objects, faces, and things like that,
pretty high level things.	Eventually, that information going to places where you're going to more actions
and decision-making, and so on. We understand some of the high level structure of the brain.
Like I said, it has helped us as a source of inspiration.
We still don't understand how the brain actually learns to do what it's doing.
We see the connections, we see information flowing, so that's kind of a fascinating topic.
Interviewer: But if you don't know how our brain learns, how can you possibly find out how a machine learns?
Yoshua Bengio: Oh, but for machines, we can design them based on mathematical concepts.
It's like if you're trying to build flying machines without seeing birds.
You could just based on the laws of physics that we know, and you could try to design something.
But of course, the way it happened is that the people who build those planes were highly inspired by birds,
maybe too much sometimes.	I have a nice slide about this,
which illustrates that sometimes it's not so good to imitate nature too closely. Let me think, where is it?
Maybe not, not in this presentation.
Interviewer: Like a person who attaches wings to back?.
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah, One of the first planes that was built in France by..
Interviewer: Is it possible for me to have a copy of this presentation?
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah, of course..
Interviewer: Because I..
Yoshua Bengio: Any of these things.	So he built this tentative plane by trying to imitate that,
and he called it Avion III. "Avion" means plane in French. Actually that's how the name, Avion, came up. It didn't fly.
He was trying to just copy, and he hadn't captured the required principles of flight.
So sometimes it's not enough to copy the details.	There are a lot of things we know about the brain in terms of details,
but we don't have enough of the big picture in terms of the principles.
Interviewer: Where does this all end?
Yoshua Bengio: Where does this land?
Interviewer: End..
Yoshua Bengio: End. Oh, you know, research never ends. We always...
Interviewer: Suppose you're right..
Yoshua Bengio: ...have more to learn.
Interviewer: Suppose you're right with your research, where does it end?
Yoshua Bengio: Why should it end?
Interviewer: Do you have a first goal? Something that you'd like to reach?
Yoshua Bengio: Well, it may be...it's hard for me to think of a day
when we will actually have researched this goal because it seems so far right now.
But yeah, it's possible to imagine one day that we fully understand the principles that make us intelligent,
and maybe we go onto other questions.
Interviewer: You know which questions?
Yoshua Bengio: Our descendants will have questions I'm sure. Humans always have questions.
Interviewer: Is a questions like, "What is love?" One like that?
Yoshua Bengio:  [laughs] Well, one thing that's true is that we're focusing on some aspect of who we are here,
like sort of pure understanding, pure intelligence learning.
Of course, we are much more than that, talking about love, emotions in general,
and people are starting to try to connect the dots for these aspects as well.
This is a kind of beginning, and also, connect to other related disciplines like sociology or anthropology
and how humans build societies and interact..
Interviewer: What do you think..
Yoshua Bengio: All of these aspects are not taking into consideration our understanding of how we are able to take
decisions because we don't understand that enough.
Of course, in psychology, there are lots of theories, and I won't diminish that at all.
Clearly we're missing a lot of that understand, and so when we make progress with that,
I think the connections with other sciences that have to do with humans will be important.
Interviewer: Do you think it's ever possible for a computer to love?
Yoshua Bengio: If we program them to, yes.
Interviewer: What yes?
Yoshua Bengio: Why?
Interviewer: What, yes? I try to...forget my question.
Yoshua Bengio: As far as I'm concerned, emotions are like anything else.
They can be understood, and we can have programs
or equations that follow the moves that correspond to the underlying mechanisms.	We have a tendency to put emotions as
something magical, that isn't accessible to science. I don't think so.
I think we're understanding more and more about them, and we will even more in the future.
Once we do that, it's good for us. We can be less stupid with our emotions, as [laughs] I think we are right now.
Interviewer:  [laughs] That's part of the charm of life.
Yoshua Bengio: Famous scientists like Einstein were saying things like,
"It's not incompatible to have understanding of the universe and how things work and feeling the charm of life
and the awe in front of the universe and its beauty," and so on. These are not incompatible.
In fact, it's the opposite.
The more we understand something, the more we can love something, and we can feel impressed or motivated,
or whatever the emotion.
Interviewer: You showed this magazine, can you take it?
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah, sure.
Interviewer: What does it say?
Yoshua Bengio: So they chose to highlight some progress in science,
and one thing that is true is that artificial intelligence research in the last year
or two has been making incredible progress.
And of course, that's one of the reasons why we hear so much about it in media, and also companies are investing.
and so on. They chose an advance..
Interviewer: What does it say on the cover?
Yoshua Bengio: Oh,
so it says this is a special issue that they do every year about ten discoveries of the year that they have selected,
and they chose to talk about some of the things we've done in my lab as well as in some of my colleagues' lab.
[inaudible 00:19:49] is actually at NYU.
Interviewer: Can you show it?
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah, yeah.
So is there no pictures except for me here, but what it's talking about is, in French here, it says,
"It's the end of a belief about neural networks."	One of the reasons why the whole approach to neural networks was kind
of abandoned for more than a decade is that people have this false belief that it would be very difficult to train,
because learning would have to get stuck in what we call local [inaudible 00:20:28]
where from which there's no small improvement that the system can make to improve itself.	We showed some evidence that
this is not the case. In fact, the bigger the neural net, the less likely this is going to be the case.
And we showed some empirical, some experimental evidence that in fact these local [inaudible 00:20:59]
people thought existed.
They do exist, but they correspond to very good configurations,
very good settings.	I think it helps to understand why these neural nets that we have now, especially the bigger ones,
are working so well, in spite of this belief that people thought it was hopeless just a few years ago.
Interviewer: For me to understand, or in a few words, what are the neural net?.
Yoshua Bengio: So, a neural net is a..
Interviewer: Just a moment.
Yoshua Bengio: A neural net is a computer program, or a computer simulation,
that's inspired buy the biological neural nets, that is able to learn from examples.
It has a structure, I can maybe find some slides that illustrate.	It's composed of little units, which make,
which compute. So we use a very cartoon neural net with some inputs...	There's another one.
Where is it?	...some inputs.
These are supposed to be standing for artificial neurons, or we call them units,
and they're connected to other neurons that are connected to other neurons.
And then some of these are actually the outputs that produce the actions,
and some of those would be the inputs that correspond to persecution.	The information flows in your brain through many
layers like this.
We have designed little equations that define what each of these artificial neurons is doing with computation.
It does very very simple things.	The connections between neurons are things that can be changed while the system is
learning.
And we have algorithms, so computer recipes,
that tell us how that change should be done so that next time the system sees another example,
it will be more likely to produce the right answer, or at least the answer that we wanted.
Interviewer: Another one, just for me to understand, can you explain to me what is a neuron?
Yoshua Bengio: Yes. So you can think...these are graphical depictions to neurons.
They're connected to other neurons through little filaments, and they connect to some places called synapses.
They're signals, electrical spikes, that travel
and allow these neurons to communicates with each other.	Each of these neurons is doing something very simple.
They're receiving those signals coming from other neurons, and they're just adding them up basically.
But they can give different importance to some of the signals that they're receiving.
These are called a synaped weights.
It's just a sum of products essentially, adding and multiplying, very simple things.
Of course, this is a simplification of what is going on in real neurons,
but it's a very useful simplification.	There are also some more complicated operations that are happening inside the
neuron that allow it to, at the end of the day, do a little piece of computation, such that if we many such neurons,
so we have a neural network, so a neural network is just a bunch of these neurons connected to each other,
they can actually compute very complicated things.
In fact, we can prove that if you have enough neurons, you can compute almost anything that a [inaudihble 00:24:55]
computer could compute.	The question then is,
how do we make sure that that neural network computes the things that we want, that are useful for us,
like recognizing objects, answering questions, understanding speech? That's where the learning comes.
The learning is about gradually changing those weights that control the importance that each neuron gives to the
neighbor to which they are connected.
Interviewer: But when you learn, then you also remember.
Yoshua Bengio: Yes, exactly.
Interviewer: How does it remember?
Yoshua Bengio: Well, it remembers because each time the network sees an example and makes some small changes,
it's going to be more likely to reproduce that kind of example, or produce the right answer for that example.
So it remembers what it should have done for this example, or at least, it remembers little bits.
If you repeat that example, then it basically learns it by heart. But it may learn things by heart.
It may be okay to teach it with some mistakes,
and it will kind of listen to the majority of what it sees to come up with a good general answer.
Interviewer: Okay. I think I understand. So what is the thing you are most excited about, yourself?
Yoshua Bengio: So what I'm most excited about what we call unsupervised learning.
That's the area of research,
which tries to make computers learn without having to tell them in detail what they should be doing.
We'd show the computer lots of text, or lots of videos, and it would learn about language
or about how images are formed just by these observations.	That's something that we know is really important for really
progressing towards the eye because one, we know that humans do that a lot; and two,
we can't afford to continue as we are doing now by providing the computer with very details prescription of what it
should be doing or how to interpret ate each answer or each sentence, and so on.
We can do some of it, but the computer would have access to a lot more information, a lot more data,
a lot more examples, if it was better at unsupervised learning.
Interviewer: Do you think in the near future, this computer, which is able to learn by itself,
can you say then that the computer comes alive?
Yoshua Bengio: Can you say that the computer comes alive?
Yeah, that's a good question.	There's some different definitions of life, of course,
and many of these definitions have been produced to fit life as we know it on Earth.
We would have to extend our notion of what life means.
But it's not inconceivable that if we're able to build machines that can learn more by themselves
and can take their own decisions, basically,
that it will start looking like a living being.	It will be hard to say that they're not alive,
except that if it's like today's machines, we can just turn them off whenever we want.
In fact, we only turn them on for the time of an experiment.
It's not like these things are sitting all the time, right?
We just run an experiments where, it's like, we have the machine start a new life,
and it goes through some experience and we test it, and then that's it.
There's no consciousness in these things and no lasting state.
Interviewer: But does it need consciousness?.
Yoshua Bengio: Not for most of the things we need those machines to do. We could have..
Interviewer: But for a machine to be alive, does it need consciousness because when it's alive
and without consciousness then we have a problem.
Yoshua Bengio: It depends, first of all, by what you mean by "alive,"
but I think we could have computers that are very very intelligent without being conscious,
without having a self-consciousness. They could be very very useful to us.
They could help us solve a lot of problems that we have around us and help us make our world better,
and that doesn't require consciousness. I don't think so.
But humans being what they are, I suppose one day people will try to put in some kind of consciousness in computers,
in intelligent machines.
Interviewer: It's just the question of time, I guess.
Yoshua Bengio: Yeah. I guess, but it's pretty far away.